so this is what it looks like okay now
sorry oh it's not it's another boy do I
can't doesn't matter suppose you oh can
you look at it carefully for me and
raise your hand if you've done this
question why so let's just say have you
given it a shot raise your hand if you
recognize this question at all and
you've tried it anyone yes I hope your
hands out of you guys who got it out or
who's Crawford in there it's a one I
checked okay you're fine I did your
swabby okay all right so therefore the
rest of you most of you have not looked
at this question and you need to this is
the classic kind of its inverse trig and
it's a domain range question right which
seems like it should be fairly standard
okay but because of how they've knocked
around with the with the nervous thing I
should give you some language for this
this thing here okay we've so far we've
been calling it like in chain rule we
call it the inside function okay but
that's kind of a in a formal way to say
and we need a better word for it
actually has a problem properly it's
called the argument um I don't know what
if it has anything to do with like
having an argument but that's that's
English for you if you do it true story
my daughter now cuz she can read my
daughter can read so she's forever
asking me what does this mean right like
and share religiosity she's like what
does foundation me and I'm like I'm just
reflecting on this question right I'm
like it could mean so many different
things certainly the based on business I
wouldn't be surprised which is I want a
closer okay so i don't know has anything
to do with you know having a debate or
anything but um it's called the eigen so
i'm going to use that word right now
because the argument has been changed
it's not just X now that's where all the
problems for this question come from
okay so even though it's really quite
simple that's the issue so let's start
theme out domain and range domain firsts
will move on to read okay how do we
autumn the earlier work out if I just
gave you you know stock standard sine
inverse
and I said state the domain what would
it work the intimate minus one sorry so
what inclusive right okay now as we
change the arguments right we know what
to do human so suppose I said let's do X
plus 3 okay what do I have to adjust
which I should do it on a new line sorry
so let's do sine inverse of X plus 3 so
what should I write okay so i can do it
think about it two ways i can think
about it as a shift okay because when
you've got x plus 3 i'm modifying the X
I'm going that way okay so you can just
take those values and push them to the
left yeah alternatively I could do it
algebraically right which will amount to
the same thing because now i subtract
three from everything which gives you
minus four final 2-2 okay so there's
your domain yeah as you can see the
algebraic method is a bit more versatile
but you can you can take much more kinds
of questions with it because when you
have a look at this argument there's no
shift involved it's just totally in the
wrong kind of like how would you move
this around it's not just this moved
around ok so I'm going to apply the same
kind of logic though to work out the
domain I want the argument to be between
minus 1 and 1 that's the way that it
works ok so therefore i'll take the
argument and i'll apply this boundary to
it ok now this is the idea however this
point so let's go back at this point
what you would do is you just muck
around with it you add stuff when you
divide or whatever in order to get just
X on its own but for a variety of
reasons having X is the subject making
excess subject here the inequalities two
of them right it's a little more
complicated right number one you've got
the square number two it's just sort of
nestled in the only the fashion it's a
bit weird ok so a better approach would
be you know if you guys got given this
question you might have been given the
question like this in the previous user
because that's when we did inequalities
right how would you approach it if you
just give that as a question solve that
what would you
one thing you could do is you can split
into two inequalities okay though then
you've got the same problem okay well
how am I going to deal with this Oh is
your suggestion bring it okay say the
same idea yet not i did a mess baby can
you okay so can we take the reciprocal
of everything okay if I say you know
solve this one over X is less than five
okay my child what does one over X look
like looks like this so five somewhere
up here okay and intersect at wet one is
that the detective work okay so where is
this true where is this inequality
satisfied less then so I want less than
0 over here and okay so does it work if
I just turn things over if I just if I
just flip things take the reciprocal of
the left that's fine take the reciprocal
of the right so I am multiple kinds of
wrong here right not only am I missing
things but this is going the wrong way
okay and part of that is because what if
you've actually multiplied through by
people anyway that's a bit see we did a
qualities Victoria this before take your
reciprocals square e those are the kinds
of things which are you really only work
with the qualities okay burn anywhere
yeah yeah that's part of the problem
that's going to account for the
direction in the inequality okay but you
know this guy down here that's a whole
other problem enters just totally got
ignored ok so I'm going to suggest
taking the reciprocal not such a great
idea okay involved
okay shall do this and then you x
everything 5 plus square and then you
end up with somewhere in the middle
where X cannot be hmm ok alright so so
we're going to go for an algebraic
method here ok now I think that will
work I think that's probably best way to
go why can I x 1 plus x squared Y is
that ok ok so that will work again we
can deal with each branch on its own I
know I know we keep doing this but uh I
know you hate to graph but I'm going to
suggest we work out what this looks like
visually ok it will help us or what when
we go into the next question I'm gonna
run outside ok now because we're running
out of time let's do I'm going to do
this in in short form ok I'm just having
a look at this ok that x squared what it
tells me is that this is going to be an
even function you see that you see that
you put an X minus X in what manner ok
so now I'm just going to work out one
side it looks like and then I'll just
flipped over ok what happens as X
approaches infinity ok so more
specifically there's a horizontal
asymptote at ok what's happening at the
at the access at the at the y axis what
x equals 0 what are you equal to aha
right r 1 over 2 times 1 ok you can go
ahead later on if you want you can
verify the stationary point here this is
the kind of shape that you get
ok anyway oh that's um that's my graph
ok now that i have a graph i can answer
this question this question says look at
this graph and tell me where is that
graph between minus 1 and 1 ok now on
this graph where's minus 1 it's all the
way down here ok and where's one it's up
here so for what values of x is this
inequality satisfy some answer all
values of x ok so there's the first
answer to my question ah there you go so
this guy exists for all real values of x
ok fine all right now so does not exist
think about it how have I I got to why
don't even ask this question on Twitter
what although the clothes is sine
inverse right that's where I got this
problem and now I'll satisfy the
inequality there's my solution so
therefore does this book it works ok it
works right now let's keep going range
how am I going to answer the question of
rage now this is a bit tricky I don't
actually know what the languages to
describe this but I suppose I suppose
range for this you don't be confused
because there's range of the argument
domain eventually are you and then
there's domain a major the whole thing
ok I want you now look at the range of
the argument in here ok what is the
range why is that
so this is actually why I guess my cool
I call this one okay I'm looking at this
guy here yes where does this exist now
these are the values this is the
argument right these are the values that
are going to go into here right and I'm
never going to get anything outside here
I'm never going to get even negative
never going to get anything above a half
ok so now i'm going to try out what
happens when you put these values in ok
so you can think this through because
this is all continuous ok so i'm not
gonna have any breaks or anything for
instance what's going to be sine inverse
of well let's let's take you up boundary
because i can i can actually take this
boundary right what's sine inverse of a
half this is piled 6 okay now hold on
for a second if i wanted to go hide now
if i wanted to get a higher value for y
ok like pie on 3 or pound for pound 2 or
something like that ok what kind of
argument would i need in order to get a
higher angle here what have you I need
to be going right instead of a half I
want like root 3 on written or two or
one or something this value needs to go
higher the argument right but the
problem is the argument can't go higher
right a half is its limit right it's
never going to go above this I'll never
get into a position where I have to do
sigh number three on two yes or so I'm
sorry Cyrus or service of one this
argument is going though
I'm gonna keep on so many especially cuz
I what's not okay so that's as high as
i'm going to go that's my upper limit
okay so here's the first part of my
range high on six okay but i also have a
lower boundary right it's never gonna go
below zero yeah it's never going to
reach the earth right so just for the
sake of argument even though i'm not
going to get it what is sine inverse of
zero also zero right now don't forget
I'm never going to get there I'll get
close but I'll never reach there so the
same way I'm going to have this kind of
value okay now on all night okay let's
do this next less good right but when
you take this and this to get off okay
and you can differentiate if you like to
prove you take the whole lot and then
you'll get a stationary point you're
going to get this same shape behave in
exactly the same way when you take sine
inverse of the law okay with one
exception domains the same range is
almost the same it's not zero door half
its zero plan C okay so there for me to
take sine inverse of the whole lot this
is the single change you need to make
that's it okay and that's the graph that
you end up with okay now i'm sort of
clear shots and ran out of time okay by
the applied calculus to be sure you can
see how it's behaving you can sub in
some values to be double double short
okay